and finally new rule before Americans
can laugh and how pathetic Cubans are
for driving those old patched up cars
instead of getting new ones we have to
explain why that's what we're doing with
our health care system our voting system
our energy policy and our infrastructure
now what apologies to my friend Jay Leno
I am NOT a car guy I don't know [ __ ]
about him they all look alike to me I
don't know who makes what and I don't
care but I know if this video was taken
recently it must be from Cuba and the
reason for the time warp is that these
cars are the same ones Cuba had back
when America imposed its embargo and so
their cars are stuck forever in 1959 and
the Cubans are forced to make the best
with what little they have like what
Trump does with his hair but in the case
of the plucky Cubans it means endlessly
patching up their old DeSoto's and Etzel
x' with whatever they can scrounge old
tractor parts chicken wire the bones of
prostitutes Rush Limbaugh killed on
vacation oh the horn on this Buick
Roadmaster is provided by squeezing a
monkey's ball so I get why they do this
what I want to know is what's our excuse
why does America address so many of its
problems by jerry-rigging the old
instead of starting fresh with something
new why don't we put in completely new
state-of-the-art water pipes instead of
just patching up the old ones from 100
years ago when we thought LED was a
vitamin same with roads and bridges
chris Christie once held up traffic on
the George Washington Bridge I'm not
sure the George Washington Bridge could
hold up Chris Christie
and driving a 59 Chevy may be
embarrassing but when it comes to
elections whilst we're still trying to
keep the 1787 model on the road and that
model runs on gerrymandering and the
Electoral College so of course it runs
like [ __ ] we're we're still using this
thing and signing this thing which
always makes me feel like I'm checking
into the Bates Motel how come the NSA
can turn on the camera in my laptop and
watch me while it reads my email but I
need to show ID to vote why can't I just
say hi government you probably don't
recognize me in my clothes but I'd like
to vote and the next time we fix the
healthcare system let's not let's make a
brand new one instead of cobbling
together some Rube Goldberg monstrosity
of exchanges and tax credits of
insurance industry concessions Obamacare
it should be called MacGyver care the
president has said that he would have
preferred a single-payer system if we
were starting from scratch so let's
start from scratch I don't get it
Americans throw out their old smartphone
every six months like it has cooties
withing noting of getting new hips new
knees new livers new wives but we can't
tear ourselves away from sucking oil out
of the ground and burning it or cutting
off the tops of mountains
what no whale oil
let's switch to solar and win by
actually switching work
we're killing the planet if someone is
stabbing you you don't look for ways to
build on the existing stabbing while
gradually shifting to a less stabbed
basis one reason young people are
attracted to Bernie is because they
haven't accepted that things can never
change that the only car you'll ever
know is a rusty old piece of [ __ ] and
your choices are learned to love it or
walk I'm just saying it's been a while
since we had that new country smell